le parc france miniature a rouvert ses
portes le 9 avril dernier avec cette
année une nouveauté un espace entier
dédié à l'univers koh lanta et pour en
parler qui de mieux puis une double
gagnante en 2005 et 2018 clémence castel
bonjour bonjour est ce que vous avez le
temps déjà de faire un petit tour sur le
lieu commence commencé ici effectivement
j'ai eu le temps de faire un petit tour
sur le lieu avec mes enfants en plus
donc qu'ils sont les meilleurs testeurs
je pense pour pour cet univers est vrai
dans cet univers on retrouve l'univers
koh lanta évidemment et toutes les
épreuves qui vont avec il ya une épreuve
de chasse au trésor c'est un milieu très
très aquatique donc forcément dans koh
lanta on retrouve de l'eau que ce soit
sur les plages ou même par la pluie
malheureusement parfois donc sa nuit
vers très très aquatique et puis voilà
il ya toute une structure en bois en
boukera qui rappelle à l'épreuve des
bambous dans koh lanta et voilà pour
tous les fans de l'émission ben voilà
ils vont retrouver tout tout ce qui
entoure et tout ce qui fait rêver dans
koh lanta c'est à dire laventure le
dépassement de soi et je suis sûr que
tous les familles vont passer un très
bon moment dans cet univers comme vous
avez dû vous avez pu vous essayer à
quelque chose est-ce qu'il ya votre une
épreuve de prédilection je vous préférez
puisque les autres a pas forcément les
poteaux c'est une épreuve que
j'affectionne particulièrement et ils
sont présents dans cet univers là c'est
super parce qu'ils restent accessibles à
une hauteur accessibles des plus jeunes
donc on peut y participer en famille
c'est ça que je trouve génial de toucher
du doigt l'ambiance de koh lanta à 25 km
de paris et qui faisait en famille donc
c'est vraiment super c'est un univers
qui essayent de représenter aussi
l'univers comme ça que vous avez dit
aussi le parc france miniature qui est
un peu un espace ludique où on apprend
ça c'est ça représente bien ces valeurs
là ici cet îlot de koh lanta mais en
fait moi c'est ma première à france
miniature aujourd'hui j'y l'occasion de
déjà faire un tour et ce qui est génial
c'est que effectivement on voit tous les
monuments français et ça m'a déjà permis
de d'expliquer beaucoup de choses à mes
enfants donc ça c'est génial et puis et
voilà il ya le côté ludique aussi il ya
des jeux l'univers koh lanta on touche
du doigt le l'esprit un petit peu des
îles etc tout en s'amusant donc donc
tout est réuni pour passer un bon moment
donc ça vient aussi à la suite d'un
autre univers fort boyard que vous avez
fait aussi une fois ouais est-ce que
vous avez le temps de visiter un peu la
salle l'antre du père fouras oui oui je
suis allé dans l'univers fort boyard
c'est une émission fort boyard qui a
commencé quand j'avais 5 ans et je me
rappelle très bien de la première année
c'est une émission qui a plus de 30 ans
aujourd'hui et qui m'a fait rêver en
tant que
jeune fille et petite fille donc voilà
on a déjà fait des épreuves avec des
enfants on peut se mesurer les uns aux
autres dans un bon état d'esprit et
voilà que soit l'univers koh lanta
l'univers fort boyard moi c'est tout ce
que j'aime le côté aventure le côté
dépassements et et voilà je suis chaka
prend apprentis aventuriers à venir ici
découvrir tous ces univers bon j'aurais
bien aimé vous affrontez haut à
l'épreuve des poteaux mais je crois de
toute façon j'aurais perdu serait
peut-être un peu de temps
mais voilà si vous voulez n'y a pas de
souci j'ai trois heures devant moi donc
ce n'est pas de problème merci beaucoup
queiroz à moscou